the worst thing about Chris Christie is
that he too willingly associates with
people who seem to be thugs uh people
for whom politics is really a means and
not an end uh bridgegate everyone knows
what that is uh what's more I don't I
don't think he knew about an advanced
what's more distressing is he hired
people who would do that gleefully and
thought that that would somehow please
him that really really worries me to
serve me and that suggests that his
judgment when it comes to people
surround themselves with is not good at
all yeah that's a very very very very
important quality in presidential
candidate don't all politicians need
those people though don't they need the
people i watch house of cards you know I
mean I know what Doug Stamper is doing
don't they all have these people whether
they are publicly aligned with them that
much or not though they have these guys
that are getting stuff done whether we
like it or not yeah but we don't know
but so his mistake is that we know and
that what I'm talking about women sake
he doesn't done see me care doesn't care
that's the mistake mistake is not that
course everyone associates with people
that you know may or may not be
completely kosher for you know for not
just for Passover but for for you know
for every for every holiday that people
who share our religion you know with
celery but yeah uh but he just had had
an arrogance about him through a lot of
the scandal and the arrogance kind of
comes through generally uh but is the
arrogance maybe what won the scandal for
him because even though I know there's
still stuff going on right now but in a
way he was so adamantly i did not know
from beat one and then sort of browbeat
a lot of the reporters to the point that
this is gonna be behind him it that
seems pretty obvious to me i don't know
i mean i think i think there's there's
there's more there and i think look
again because of the fact Republican
elites hate him for the most part
they're gonna be the ones digging this
out it's not going to be Democrats
you're digging out of stuff against him
but when you're looking for president
you you want people to associate with
people you know who are smart and do the
right thing if they don't you want them
to be able to figure out why they why
they didn't and then fix that and and uh
and I I just think that you know beyond
this question of bullying because
frankly again I have this kind of grand
third that Americans kind of want to
bully yeah in that that's what I'm very
well
Tony Soprano but but they don't want
[ __ ] there's a difference between
bullet bully I know he's not a thug yeah
the people that he's random seem to be
allegedly some of them thugs that's a
really really really negative trait to
associate with the presidential
candidate